good evening it's good to see everyone
here again this evenings message is
called a king shall reign rebuilding the
temple of God and I want to open to a
text of Scripture in Hagee I chapter 2
last evening when we were here we talked
about Ichabod the glorious departed and
we want to look at that again as we
continue through this study in the days
of Nebuchadnezzar when he came to take
Jerusalem on the last and final the last
and final surrounding of the city Ellen
White as well as Josephus indicate that
one of the prophets
and I believe Josephus indicates that it
was probably Jeremiah but one of the
prophets had secret of the Covenant away
they did not want that Ark to be taken
again as it had been in King David's day
and because that Ark was taken away you
had a span of between four and five
hundred years where there was no Ark
behind the veil so when Jesus came to
the earth and he went into the temple in
John chapter two and he said you know
destroy this temple and in three days I
will raise it up most Christians do not
realize that at the time that he was
speaking there still was no Ark of the
Covenant behind the veil now as an
example of that the scripture tells us
that people in the last days will have a
form of godliness but no power thereof
that was what that was a symbol of they
went through the
oceans every single day every week every
month and even every year and you have
to think about Dave atonement you know
when the high priest was supposed to go
within the veil and sprinkle the mercy
seat for almost 500 years there had been
no mercy seat what they did I don't know
it would be interesting to find out but
the Jewish people I'm sure some of the
priesthood knew but the majority of the
Jewish people had no idea they went in
and they were going through the motions
and there was no Ark behind the veil now
because of that when the children of
Israel were set free from Babylonian
captivity after 70 years when they went
back under the direction of Nehemiah and
Ezra to rebuild the city of Jerusalem
and to rebuild the temple they began
laying the foundation stone and getting
everything prepared and once they got
everything ready there was a shout that
went up and it talks about that here in
Haggai and it's interesting too because
it says in verse 1 of chapter 2 in the
seventh month in the one and twentieth
day of the month that was called
Tabernacles another name for Tabernacles
is God with us that was in the Jewish
economy that was that day or that holy
period that they celebrated right after
Day of Atonement
now the Advent movement originally
before we were known as seventh-day
Adventists if you look up all the
historical documents we were known as
the seventh month movement because we
had been studying about Day of Atonement
and what happened on Day of Atonement in
the seventh month so this scripture has
a great deal of importance to us the
seventh day Evan is Christian
but what's amazing is is this when this
shout went up from the thousands of
people that were there the older men of
God that could remember Solomon's Temple
they were weeping and the young men were
shouting for joy the ones that had not
seen Solomon's Temple and it tells that
you couldn't distinguish who was weeping
and who was shouting and then it
actually asked the question the Lord
asked the question he says when you look
at this house that has been rebuilt what
is it in comparison in your eyes to that
which Solomon had built Solomon's Temple
was one of the seven wonders of the
world I mean everyone in the world
wanted to see what had happened there
under Solomon's reign Jerusalem was it
was unreal they said that gold and
silver were like the stones on the
street that was literal there was so
much wealth and prosperity there as long
as Solomon was living for the Lord but
because of Israel sins that's why they
had been sent into captivity and the
throne of God had been hidden away so
now these young men were so excited
because they knew once the temple is
rebuilt God will show us where the
throne is the Ark of the Covenant and
once that throne is there the king will
return to reign that was important
because with the King on the throne
they knew I'm talking about the Lord God
they knew no one can defeat us
none of our enemies we will not go back
into captivity again
now listen to what it says in verse 6 it
says for thus saith the Lord of hosts
yet once it is but a little while and I
will shake the head
even's and the earth and the sea and the
dry land and I will shake all nations
and the desire of all nations shall come
that's where we get the title the desire
of Ages and if you want a reference for
this when you get home look up Hebrews
chapter 12 verses 25 through 29 because
it quotes this verse for our day it says
I will shake all nations that means all
the tribes of the earth and the desire
of all nations shall come and I will
fill this house with glory saith the
Lord of Hosts now I want to stop there
for a moment in our previous study we
looked at the fact that God said that
from the very beginning of creation it
was his purpose that every created being
should be a temple for him to dwell in
does everyone remember that okay when
Adam and Eve sinned because of sin God
had to step out of that temple and a
temple without the presence of God is
dark have you ever considered that in
the most holy place was the glory of God
in the holy place you only had one form
of light that was the seven lamps and
those lamps were supposed to be a
reflection of the glory that was behind
the veil if you took the glory out from
behind the veil darkness came upon the
the tabernacle the only light left was
just the the candlestick the menorah and
without God's presence there the menorah
is meaningless he says I will fill this
house with glory saith the Lord the
desire of Nations was that the king
would return that the glory would be
brought back into the temple not just a
physical temple but for those that had
spiritual eyesight the temple that we
are what happened with sin was the light
went out we lost that garment of light
but the desire of all nations is for
that light to be brought back and the
Lord goes on in verse 9 and he says and
the glory of this latter house shall be
greater than of the former saith the
Lord of hosts and in this place I will
give peace in what place Jerusalem the
word Jerusalem means the city of peace
but have you ever considered that Christ
is the temple he is the sanctuary and in
him the Apostle Paul says in Ephesians
chapter 1 and 2 we have been given
perfect peace the last promise Jesus
gave to us before Calvary was my peace
give I unto you let not your heart be
troubled neither let it be afraid and I
used to read that it was just words on a
page but it hit me one day I know what
it feels like if I slip and fall into
sin and everybody does but what if
you've done what if you've done worse
than slip and fall what if you were
tempted and you knew it was a temptation
and you yield it anyway some people you
know maybe they get victory in two or
three days there's been times in my life
where I would go for a month or more
struggling to hear God's voice again and
Christ tells us my peace give I unto you
Jesus never
had one single day in his entire life
that he was afraid he had lost the
presence of God the only time he ever
even hints at that was when the sins of
the world were being laid upon him in
Gethsemane and on Calvary he woke up
every single day rejoicing to go and
meet his father he was never guilty he
was never worried about have I messed up
is God angry at me and Christ makes a
promise to us in John chapter 13 14 and
15 he says my peace I give to you let
not your heart be troubled neither let
it be afraid he knew he was going to
take our sins upon himself the Bible
says in 2nd Corinthians 5:21 God has
made Christ to be sins for us who knew
no sin he laid upon him the iniquities
of us all God goes on and in 1st Samuel
and in Zechariah and he says and I will
raise me up a faithful priest that shall
do according to that which is in my
heart and Jesus had already said I
delight to do thy will o my god yea your
law is within my heart God said I will
build him a sure house and he shall walk
before mine anointed forever that's
talking about you and I Christ will go
before us and Christ will be our rear
guard zechariah 6 says and he shall
build the temple of the lord and he
shall bear the glory and he shall sit
and rule upon his throne and he shall be
a
priest upon his throne and the council
of peace shall be between them both and
I want to I want to make a note of this
this is an important text of Scripture
there's only one other person in the
entire Bible that was King and priest at
the same time Melchizedek and it says
Christ was made a high priest after the
order of Melchizedek
I grew up thinking that Christ was
wearing the robes of a high priest but
one day he'll take those robes off and
he'll sit down and he'll be anointed
king read the last chapter of desire of
Ages she tells that he was inaugurated
at Kay as king when he ascended on high
he is both priest and king at the same
time we're not waiting for him to take
the throne go through the New Testament
and look up every single verse where it
says when he ascended on high he sat
down at the right hand of the Majesty on
high jesus answered and said unto them
in john chapter 2 destroy this temple
and in three days I will raise it up
then said the Jews forty in six years
was this temple in building wilt thou
rear it up in three days but this Jesus
spake of the temple of his body
Ephesians 5 says which temple we are for
we are members of his body and of his
flesh and his bones
jesus said destroy this temple and in
three days I'm going to raise it up a
lot of times people will they'll quote
what the devil whispers to
you know the devil knows the Bible I
mean you know he knows the Bible he
twists the Scriptures he quoted
scripture to Jesus but he twisted it
Ellen White says Satan is a legalist he
does not understand mercy he wants the
full extent of the law for every
transgressor that's why when Christ came
to resurrect Moses Satan resisted him he
said he sinned your law says the wages
of sin is death and Christ said the Lord
rebuke thee Christ said I know I'm gonna
pay for his sin it's done I already gave
my word and I cannot lie I am verily God
I cannot lie I made a covenant with my
father in heaven before the foundation
of the world and do you know what that
covenant was greeted in patriarchs and
prophets the first two chapters she said
that the father called his son into that
unapproachable glory and he told his son
I want to have a family we have got a
huge house but it's just angels
I want sons and daughters not just sons
and daughters by creation like an angel
could be their ministering servants I
want children and he told his son we're
gonna have a family and you can imagine
you know with sanctified imagination how
Christ must have felt knowing he's not
going to be an only child anymore and he
proverbs chapter 8 says his delights
were with the sons of men that's why
Christ loved to come down here with Adam
and Eve that was his greatest pleasure
during the day the father looked at his
son and he said but they're gonna fall
and there's only one way that we can
redeem them and he explained to Christ
that Christ would have to become a human
being he would have to take
our nature in its fallen condition not
just like it was the day after Adam fell
but after 4000 years of man falling to
sin and I want to interject a thought
here to Ellen White also says we are not
to make Christ identical to ourselves
she said that's an impossibility we're
born with one nature fallen Christ was
born with two nature's man's fallen
nature and the very nature and presence
of Almighty God within and through the
power of his father's Spirit the Holy
Spirit dwelling within him he conquered
sin in fallen human nature now what
happened was the father told his son
you're gonna have to bear their sins
that doesn't mean just simply take the
beating for what they did wrong if we go
through our lives thinking that's all
Christ did he gives us a terrible
picture of our Father in heaven Ellen
White says that Christ actually felt the
guilt and the shame for the sins
iniquities and transgressions of every
human being that has ever lived as if he
had committed them himself when he was
on Calvary he felt like what I felt when
I had abandoned my wife and children he
felt my guilt and your guilt for every
wrong thought and act we've ever
committed for the entire human race and
God looked at his son and said this is
what's gonna have to take place and you
know what Christ did he didn't even
hesitate he put his hand out and he said
daddy Abba I'll bear the sins of every
human being
even if I never see life again and do
you know what his father did and I I
have to imagine that it was with tears
in his eyes he put out his hand to take
his son's hand and he said if you will
bear their sins I swear to you I'll
forgive every one of them and I'll raise
you from the dead that is the counsel of
peace that was between them both and
when Christ was there at Calvary and he
couldn't see past the portals of the
tomb it was his human nature but at the
very last he said father into thy hands
I commend my spirit that was the faith
that my father cannot lie hallelujah
from eternal ages it was God's purpose
that every created being from the bride
and holy sareth an angel to man should
be a temple for the indwelling of the
creator but because of sin
humanity ceased to be a temple for God
darkened and defiled by evil the heart
of man no longer revealed the glory of
the divine one now listen to this the
work of God in the creation of man
needed no one doing there was nothing
imperfect nothing incomplete he spake
and it was done the very dust of the
ground from which man was formed was
pure and the breath of life which God
breathed into his nostrils was holy he
was placed in Eden the garden of God and
its atmosphere was undefiled and from
the beams of the Sun and the heavens
which blessed and cheered the earth
to the fountains and streams that
watered the garden all was holy that
means it was perfect the way God created
everything was exactly the way it was
supposed to be in the creation of God
before the entrance of sin every part of
nature was in perfection God had nothing
to take down as unnecessary to his plan
he needed to set into operation no power
by which to dispossessed do you
understand what that means we've been
talking about possession how evil
spirits come into a human life he says
everything was it was perfect it was
holy he needed to inaugurate no opposing
force but through the calamity of sin
the work of disintegration was begun and
the beautiful temple of God's building
was defiled and laid in ruins God no
longer was a dweller
in the heart of man I want to I want to
look at something for a moment and this
is important right now within Christian
circles and especially within our
denomination within our church we have a
lot of people that struggle with the
idea of obtaining Christian perfection
that's an issue do you know why it's an
issue because they've been trying for 20
30 40 years to do it on their own and
they can't get it so you know what
happens when you when you strive and
strive and strive and it just doesn't
seem to work you go obviously God
doesn't expect us to be perfect I've
tried and it didn't work so there's got
to be another I'm missing something but
God made Adam and Eve perfect and you
know what's amazing I don't know why we
struggle
so much with the idea of perfection do
you know that the entire world desires
perfection if you're a young man and you
go to the Olympics you strive with
everything in you you don't want an
eight point seven or an eight point nine
or a nine point four
you want a ten you want it to be perfect
and you know it's funny I'm gonna pick
on the ladies for a minute if you think
perfection is not desired by the entire
world look up online how much money is
spent in one year by the health and
beauty industry Cosmetics
they all want perfection every woman out
there looks in the mirror when she gets
up in the morning and probably thinks at
least for a moment oh wow
I don't look like I did when I was 20
that's why the industry is making
billions upon billions of dollars God
put within the hearts of every man and
woman the desire to return to Ayden's
perfection even the heathen they don't
even realize it but they want that so
bad and you can I'll pick on the men now
because you know I'm there with you you
know I can remember going in we'll just
pretend like it was this morning and I'm
you know bending over the sink to brush
my teeth and I look up in the mirror
just for a second I go and there used to
be more up there and men will go out and
spend thousands of dollars on whatever
to try to fix that or they look in the
mirror sideways and they're walking out
of the bathroom and they go that didn't
used to look like that now I'm gonna
have to get one of those things a girdle
to go around I need to start working out
again and it is God has put within the
hearts of every man woman and child they
want perfection
what about Miss Universe or Miss America
they want perfection that is something
God put within us but Satan said I've
got a better way an easier way that you
can obtain it listen to what a couple of
the Eastern mystics and martial artists
and gurus say Foresti Morgan he's a
major in the US Air Force I believe he
was a third dawn or is a third dawn
third degree
he said the true Bhutto aspirant that
means someone who is striving in the art
of Bushido the art of war devotes
himself to a system of physical mental
and spiritual discipline through which
he attempts to elevate himself in search
of perfection gichin funakoshi he's the
founder of modern-day karate he said the
purple purpose of martial arts
competition is not in winning or losing
but in the perfection of the character
of its participants these men and I have
hundreds of quotes these men and women
that are involved in yoga and Tai Chi
and Eastern mysticism they're all
striving for perfection some of the
internal arts will even tell you the
goal is immortality they tell you that
some of the art says you get higher up
and I'm talking about after 10 20 years
they'll tell you if you continue to
practice this you will achieve Nirvana
or Buddhahood you become an immortal the
Catholics call that saint in you you
don't really die you go on to a higher
state of existence listen to what the
Lord has inspired through hedonism Satan
had
ages turned men away from God but he won
his great triumph in perverting the
faith of Israel faith that means
trusting God's Word by contemplating and
worshiping their own conceptions the
heathen had lost a knowledge of God and
had become more and more corrupt so it
was with Israel Isaiah 58 verse 8
through 11 tells us the Lord says my
ways are not your ways neither are my
thoughts your thoughts and you know a
lot of times we think well that means
doing something well I've got to bring
myself into alignment with what he's
telling me to do he says my ways are not
your ways if I want to do something I
think about it and then I have to take
my hands and go do it and sometimes I
can have a thought and my body my
muscles doesn't want to keep up with
what my mind has pictured God's not that
way God doesn't do things that way God
speaks and it is that's the way God does
things all things he creates by his
spoken word even a clean heart the
principle that man can save himself by
his own works lay at the foundation of
every heathen religion and it had now
become the principle of the Jewish
religion Satan had implanted this
principle wherever it is held men have
no barrier against sin you want to know
why we're losing people in the church
we're not losing them because we don't
have the right kind of music we're
losing people just like all the other
churches because they have been striving
for years in their own strength and
willpower to achieve that which it's
impossible
to do on their own that's why God said
I'm going to give the last message of
love and mercy the three angels message
is righteousness holiness victory and
perfection by faith in my spoken word
Daniel when he was in captivity he cried
unto the Lord and he said Lord Daniel
chapter 9 let thine anger and thy fury
be turned away from thy city thy holy
mountain because for our sins and for
the iniquities of our fathers Jerusalem
and the high people have become a
reproach to all that are about us let me
ask you a question
our Christians are approached to the
world you better believe it do you know
what the world says you Christians are
having the same amount of sickness that
we are you have the same amount of
divorce as we do what's that you go to
the same movies you listen to the same
music you dress the same way what's the
difference between you and us now let me
bring it home a little bit closer in the
days of the Apostles right after Christ
had went back to heaven they for went
forth with power with power they healed
the sick they raised the dead they cast
out demons they cleanse lepers when's
the last time you saw that in your
church when's the last time somebody
came to your church and they were in a
wheelchair and they went home after the
service walking and they never had to
use the wheelchair again Ellen White
tells us why we don't see those kind of
miracles she said because we are not
consecrated as they were we're living
double lives we're double minded we're
still trying to hold onto a piece of the
world
or were trying to do it in our own power
rather than surrendering and letting our
God and our Savior take possession of us
she said if we would consecrate
ourselves that means surrender
everything she said the same power that
the Apostles had is ours and she said
our church would be a terror to her
enemies look that phrase up a terror to
her enemies can you imagine what it
would be like if you moved into a town
here in California and the devil got
nervous or the evil angels got nervous
and they were like they're you know what
are we gonna do so and so John just
moved in here well who's John John's
that guy that believes in the sack and
he lives it he lives for God we need to
call for backup
what if we caused them to tremble
do you know Jesus promised that he said
upon this rock I will build my church
and the gates of Hell shall not prevail
against it you know gates of a city they
never attack anybody have you ever
thought of that what does it mean the
gates of Hell will not prevail against
us gates don't attack people people
attack gates we're not called by God to
hold this little 24 inch square piece of
ground that we got when we gave our life
to Jesus and we're baptized that's how
most of us live
I've just got to stand here and I'm
trembling I'm working out my salvation
with fear and trembling and I'm doing a
lot of trembling God didn't call us to
tremble and hold this piece of ground he
told Moses and he tells us everywhere
you put your foot I've already given it
to you go take the world and Ellen
White's
is when the latter rain falls she said
men and women and even children filled
with the Spirit of the Living God will
go forth and nothing will stand before
them and then she tells us don't wait
for it to fall God is waiting for us to
claim it we don't sit here in the pew
and say well one day the light of rain
will fall if you're waiting on it it's
never gonna hit you you've got to lay
hold on that promise and claim it and
say God I will not let you go until you
fill me with the fullness of your
presence because you swore and you
cannot lie cleanse the temple of my
heart Daniel went on and he said now
therefore o our God hear the prayer of
thy servant and my supplications let
thine anger and thy fury be turned away
from thy city Jerusalem thy holy
mountain and caused thy face to shine
upon thy sanctuary which is desolate for
the lord's sake for christ's sake not
because of my sake not because of my
righteousness for his sake Isaiah
chapter 32 verse 1 and chapter 16 verse
5 listen to what the Lord promises us
behold a king shall reign in
righteousness and princes that word in
Hebrew means sons and daughters Prince's
shall rule in justice and in mercy shall
the throne be established
what was that top part of the Ark of the
Covenant called the mercy seat in mercy
shall the throne be established and he
shall sit upon it in truth in the
tabernacle of David
judging and seeking justice and hasting
quickening to flow as water
righteousness
do you remember what Jesus said in John
chapter 7 come unto me all you that are
thirsty and I will give you living water
do you know what the word living means
it means life giving when we talk about
the Living God
it means the life-giving God he says I
will sit upon this throne in Verity in
the tabernacle of David look that phrase
up in Acts chapter 15 and in the Old
Testament
it's beautiful what's there until the
Spirit be poured upon us from on high
and the wilderness be a fruitful field
and the fruitful field be reckoned as a
forest and the work of righteousness
shall be peace or Shalom and the effect
of righteousness shall be quietness and
assurance for ever do you know how many
Christians don't have assurance and I'm
gonna I'm gonna pick on those in our
denomination because I've been there I
was raised in it do you know how many
seventh-day Adventist Christians have no
assurance do you know you ask them if
they have assurance of their salvation
and you know what they'll say I hope so
I mean they're afraid I cannot tell you
how many seventh-day Adventist
Christians call me and they're afraid
they're afraid of the time of trouble
they're afraid of the close of probation
and and for some reason they think
there's an event that's gonna happen and
boom all of a sudden they're gonna have
assurance what are you waiting for
are you waiting til the plagues start
being poured out and you look and go I
don't have one I've got assurance now
let me tell you if that's what you're
waiting for you're still going to be
struggling with doubt and you know what
the Bible
says in Revelation the fearful will have
no part in the kingdom of God
they'll have their part in the lake of
fire the fearful that means those that
are afraid that's why the Bible tells us
Christ tells us I have not given you the
spirit of fear but of power of love and
of a sound mind the only thing that
holds people in bondage to fear is
because they're trying in their own
strength to achieve righteousness and
they know I'm not there so they have a
lot to be afraid of but let me tell you
something and if you want the quotes
send me an email I will send you the
articles from sister white and the
promises from God's Word if you want
assurance let your assurance be found in
His righteousness not your own because
if you've sinned once you have none you
have none that doesn't give us an excuse
for sin the Apostle Paul says shall we
continue to sin that grace may abound
god forbid how shall we that are dead to
sin live any longer therein and remember
we talked about that the other day
what's the the most common verse you
know on the state of the Dead the dead
know not anything right so if that old
man has been crucified with Christ why
are you still talking to him that's
spiritualism he's dead he has no more
anything to do with anything that's done
under the Sun the work of righteousness
shall be peace and the effect of
righteousness shall be quietness and
assurance that Sabbath that's what the
Sabbath is a sign of of resting in
perfect peace and assurance be
as you know in whom you have believed
through Christ was to be felt fulfilled
the purpose of which the tabernacle was
a symbol that glorious building with its
walls of glistening gold reflecting in
rainbow hues the curtains which were in
wrought with cherubim the fragrance of
ever burning incense pervading all the
priests robed in spotless white and in
the deep mystery of the inner place
above the mercy seat between the figures
of the bioship inane JAL's the glory of
the holiest God designed that the temple
at Jerusalem should be a continual
witness to the high destiny open to
every soul but the Jews had not
understood the significance of the
building they regarded with so much
pride they did not yield themselves as
holy temples for the Divine Spirit the
courts of the temple at Jerusalem filled
with the tumult of unholy traffic that's
buying and selling and I thought what
does that have to do with anything
inside of us do you know the Bible says
we have sold ourselves for our
iniquities that's the buying and selling
that that was a symbol of the devil
offers us a deal look I've got this sin
on special this week it won't cost you
that much you won't surely die it's only
one piece of cake at 12 o'clock at night
God won't judge you for that he sells us
that and we buy it we sell our souls for
a piece of cake do you know Adam and Eve
sold their souls for less than that it
was a piece of fruit one bite the courts
of the temple at Jerusalem filled with
the tumult of unholy traffic represented
all too true
the temple of the heart defiled by the
presence of carnal desire and unholy
thoughts but by the incarnation of the
Son of God the purpose of heaven is
fulfilled that purpose was that man
should again be a temple for their
creator and through saving grace that
means the divine influence the heart of
man becomes again his temple in all God
desired his people to read his purpose
for the human soul when we see the
sanctuary this was a picture of what he
wanted us to look like
that's why Jesus were so angry he said
why are you coming into my house and
shedding all this blood blood was poured
out for the transgression of sin God is
like I don't want you coming to church
just begging for mercy every week why
don't you accept my righteousness and
then you can come to church and instead
of begging for forgiveness and mercy you
can spend the entire Sabbath praising me
for the victory and do you know Ellen
White said that she said the only way we
can keep the Sabbath holy as if by faith
God has kept us holy throughout the week
it was the same purpose long afterwards
set forth by the Apostle Paul when
speaking by the Holy Spirit he said know
ye not that you are the temple of God
and that the Spirit of God dwelleth in
you and Jesus went up to Jerusalem and
he found in the temple those that sold
oxen and sheep and doves and the
changers of the money sitting and when
he had made a scourge of small cords he
drove them all out of this town
this is a picture of him casting out
every evil spirit that is trying to sell
you a sin and he said unto them take
these things hence and make not my
father's house a house of merchandise in
the cleansing of the temple Jesus was
announcing his mission as the Messiah
that word is only used I believe two or
three times in all of the Old Testament
Scriptures and it's all in Daniel and he
was entering upon his work to cleanse
the heart from the defilement of sin
from the earthly desires the selfish
lusts and evil habits that corrupt the
soul listen to what this man says more
eiu Asia by the founder of Aikido he
said everyone has a spirit that can be
refined a body that can be trained in
some manner a suitable path to follow
you are here to realize your inner
divinity and to manifest your innate
enlightenment pay attention to that word
enlightenment John Stevens a seventh
dawn in Aikido says martial ways our
spiritual disciplines to be practiced
for the sake of enlightenment now let me
show you what it says in Ephesians
chapter one the Lord tells us I pray
that the god of our Lord Jesus Christ
the father of glory may give unto you
the spirit of wisdom and revelation in
the knowing of him
do you remember John 17:3 this is life
eternal that we might know him not know
about him only but know him personally
like a husband and wife that we might
become
with him that the eyes of our
understanding being enlightened that you
may know what is the hope the assurance
of his calling and what is the riches of
the glory of his inheritance and the
Saints and what is the exceeding
greatness of his power to us word who
believe you want to know what his great
power is the Bible says it's him calling
life out of the dead and darkness he
calls light out of the darkness when he
raised Christ from the dead we were in
Christ when he raised Christ from the
dead Christ was guilty of the sins of
the entire human race and God raised him
that's the power of the God we serve
according to the working of his mighty
power which he wrought in Christ when he
raised him from the dead and set him at
his own right hand in the heavens look
up Isaiah chapter 66 verse 1 and 2 he
says heaven is my throne and the earth
is my footstool where is the house that
you're gonna build for me far above all
principality and powers and might and
Dominion and every name that is named
not only in this world but also in that
which is to come now I want you to hear
this what a scene was that when angels
and cherubim and Seraphim rejoiced as
they hastened through the heavenly
courts proclaiming that a ransom had
been found that God could be just and
yet also the justifier of him who
believes in the ransom that has been
provided the law could be magnified when
you magnify something you make it
clearer
and made honourable and yet fallen man
could be restored to more than his
former dignity and glory and exalted as
an overcomer of satanic hosts let
everyone who should believe in Jesus be
recreated to walk in newness of life
and from the ruins that Satan had
wrought through sin we should arise in
purity and holiness the Fallen temple of
the Lord man was to be reconstructed to
be formed after the image of Jesus
Christ the wisdom of God unto whom
coming as a living or life-giving stone
rejected indeed by men but with God he
was chosen and precious we also and I
know the King James says ye but you need
to read the scriptures like they were
written to you Ellen White said this is
written and spoken to us individually we
also as living stones are built up a
spiritual house to be a holy priesthood
to offer up spiritual sacrifices
acceptable to God through Jesus Christ
now I want to show you something
first Peter 2 or 1st Peter chapter 2
verse 9 listen to what the Apostle says
for we are a chosen generation a royal
priesthood that means kings and priests
we are a royal priesthood chosen in him
before the foundation of the world that
we should show forth the praises of him
who hath called you out of the darkness
and into his marble
less light what darkness do you think he
called us out of there is no place
darker than the tomb early on the
morning of the resurrection before
anyone had reached the Sepulcher there
was a great earthquake the mightiest
angel from heaven he who held the
position from which Satan fell received
his commission from the father and
clothed with the panoply the armory of
heaven he parted the darkness from his
track his face was like the lightning
and his garments as white as snow the
Roman guard were keeping their weary
watch when this angel came to the earth
and they were enabled to endure the
sight for they had a message to bear as
witnesses of the resurrection of Christ
the light of heaven encircled the tomb
and the whole heaven was lightened by
his glory the angel approached the grave
and rolling away the stone as if it had
been a pebble his voice was heard thou
son of God come forth thy father calls
thee and Jesus came forth from the grave
with the tread of a mighty Conqueror
there was a burst of triumph and the
mighty angel followed by the armies of
heaven bowed in adoration before him as
he the monarch of heaven proclaimed over
the rent tomb of Joseph I am the
resurrection and the life
Oh death where is thy sting o grave
where is thy victory and we are complete
in him who is head of all principality
and powers in whom also you are
circumcised with the circumcision made
without hands in putting off the body
of the sins of the flesh by the
circumcision of Christ we are buried
with him in Baptism wherein also ye are
present tense risen with him through
faith in the operation of God if you
take a 40 year old man and he's got to
be circumcised what would you call that
surgery an operation look at what the
Lord put in the King James through faith
in the operation of God who hath hath
passed hence raised him from the dead
and you being dead in your sins and the
uncircumcision of your flesh hath past
tense he quickened together with him
having forgiven you all trespasses and
you hath he quickened who were dead in
trespasses and sins and hath raised us
up together and made us sit together in
the heavens in Christ Jesus so that in
the ages to come he might show the
exceeding riches of His grace in his
kindness toward us through Christ Jesus
I want to tell you something and when we
begin this last message this evening I
want you to go home this week this
Sabbath this weekend and read Ephesians
chapter 1 and 2 and write it down every
time it says in Christ in whom in him
make a mark of it and pay attention to
the tenses of the verbs it happened
2,000 years ago that's why when Jesus
cried out on Calvary it is finished oh
man
[Music]